2021 started with most of us locked up
but no pandemic can ever stop a rich
supply of political spats
you may have been in lockdown in january
but china's warplanes weren't 28 of them
entered taiwan's air defense
identification zone including
nuclear-capable bombers and an
anti-submarine aircraft
this would be a theme for 2021 in a
nutshell beijing reckons taiwan is
rightfully theirs taiwan doesn't and the
u.s is sticking its nose in what happens
next on taiwan we best get used to this
much of this coincided with the
inauguration of new u.s president joe
biden who didn't take long to reaffirm
his commitment to taiwan's sovereignty
with sleepy joe taking the reins i like
to drive i used to think i was a pretty
good driver white house kremlin
relations went back to square one or
square
minus 10. who do you think he's a killer
i do responding today in moscow putin
said
it takes one to no one
in response russia's ambassador to the
u.s was recalled back to moscow
relations with chile before and now they
were freezing
what didn't help was another us
intelligence report which claimed that
russia interfered in the u.s elections
in 2016 by waging a disinformation
campaign
relax democrats you just lost ok
the early months of 2021 were also
marred by the most boring spat between
britain and the eu as the brexit
transition period came to an end wake up
at the back over there please it's all
about fishing and trucks i said wake up
things did nearly get interesting when
the eu's chief something or other ursula
vonderlion nearly caused a global trade
war for covid19 vaccines by threatening
to block the export of the astrazeneca
vaccine to britain because
why not we do not want to have to use
these tools
but we will not hesitate to use them if
necessary
joe biden was off to europe for
face-to-face meetings with leaders
across the continent including a guy he
just labelled a killer vladimir putin
the summit in geneva was hyped to the
high heavens and the outcome was largely
positive well nothing much happened but
hey no one died the u.s repeated its
accusation that russia had some
responsibility in dealing with the
fallout of the ransomware attack that
took down the servers of the colonial
oil pipeline in texas but prior to the
meeting biden himself admitted that
there was no evidence that russia was
behind the attack not really sure why he
brought it up then however putin also
described the summit as constructive so
all the ambassadors were returned to
their posts
so the summers got off to a pretty good
start oh wait no afghanistan is falling
apart the taliban kicked off a major
offensive ahead of the us's planned
pull-out in august by the 15th they'd
taken the whole country and western
forces scrambled to get the hell out of
dodge in late august the afghanistan
branch of isis set off a bomb at kabul
airport killing civilians and troops and
the blame game began a leaked pentagon
report suggested washington privately
blamed the uk for the attack
u.s officials claimed they'd only kept
the gate open at the airport to aid the
british evacuation because the uk
government had asked them to the uk
foreign secretary at the time dominic
raab came out and labeled the
accusations simply untrue and buck
passing ouch
quite a few cracks appearing in that
special relationship then
the summer also saw the u.s get into a
spat with another one of its allies
israel 17 media organizations across the
globe revealed that authoritarian
regimes had been spying on government
officials journalists lawyers and human
rights activists using a spyware program
called
pegasus the spyware can intercept phone
conversations texts and photos and can
even turn your mobile into a listening
device
the phone number of french president
emmanuel macron was listed in one of the
leaked databases so this thing really
did go all the way to the top but the
problem was that this software was
created and sold by an israeli-backed
tech company called nso group
awkward summer gives way to autumn
out of nowhere australia the uk and the
us
or
arcus orcus
aucus announced a trilateral security
pact part of it meant that london and
washington would help to supply
australia with a fleet of nuclear
submarines only thing was australia kind
of already promised to buy those subs
from france but the french were left
stood up at the restaurant table and
they were not happy about it but you
have to respect lies and partners and it
was not the case with this deal and i
think this is detrimental to the
reputation of your country so australia
ditched france for old joe biden but
while it may have been true love for the
aussies the u.s president couldn't even
remember their name in the morning i
want to thank
that fellow down under
thank you very much pal appreciate it mr
prime minister it's scott morrison the
australian pm i'm pretty sure you didn't
remember it either
macron appeared to carry his anger all
the way to cop 26 in glasgow where we
got a glimpse of this lovely photo if a
picture says a thousand words this one
says just one
[ __ ] mind you uk prime minister
boris johnson certainly did his best to
wind him up time for some of our dearest
friends around the world to you know
prone and grit the beef or le birth only
got worse after reports that macron
called boris a clown in charge of a
circus
you didn't have to read between the
lines of that one
and cop 26 the much hyped meeting for
world leaders to bash their heads
together and save the planet well russia
china and brazil didn't even turn up
nice one boris
it's going quite very very well
organized
and remember those warplanes that china
sent over into taiwanese airspace at the
start of the year well by october they'd
sent even more a record actually 39
warplanes to be exact of course the
us-led western alliance was also
carrying out exercises in the area
pretending to attack china so let's not
take the high ground on that one just
yet and while we're in the region
remember that wuhan lab leak theory you
know the suggestion that covet 19 may
have originated in a lab but was shut
down as a tin foil hat conspiracy theory
just a year ago well a leaked report
from october says that at least one u.s
intelligence agency believes that it did
originate in a lab but then again those
guys will believe almost anything won't
they so the moral of the story is that
when it comes to geopolitics it's the
same [ __ ]
different year
you